hola qué tal en bolivia estaban
habilitadas dos empresas privadas para
hacer conteo rápido y las dos han
presentado sus resultados pasada la
medianoche y la coincidencia es que luis
arse el candidato del movimiento al
socialismo ha ganado en primera vuelta y
además por mayoría absoluta lo que le
implica que no tendría que hacer ningún
pacto para gobernar por otro lado las
dos encuestadoras han hecho también un
mapeo de cómo ha quedado el poder
distribuido en el país y han establecido
que cinco de los nueve departamentos
están al mando del movimiento al
socialismo el partido del ex presidente
evo morales- tres departamentos quedan
para carlos meza de comunidad ciudadana
y sólo uno santacruz al mando de creemos
el partido de luís fernando camacho eso
sin embargo son resultados
extraoficiales y preliminares los
resultados oficiales están avanzando muy
lentamente en su cómputo de hecho hasta
hace unos minutos se había contabilizado
15.49 por ciento donde
se estaba ganando con 43% y el más
seguía con 34 puntos 18% eso quiere
decir que realmente este conteo todavía
no muestra una tendencia para decir
quién es finalmente el ganador porque
recién está en el 15% los resultados
oficiales se podrían conocer hasta el
viernes de esta semana sin embargo el
presidente del tribunal supremo
electoral ha prometido acelerar este
recuento para darle certidumbre al país
lo antes posible aunque hasta el momento
el conteo ha sido bastante lento